la capital de la nación se ha convertido
en una fortaleza con más de 20 mil
miembros de la guardia nacional además
de fuerzas policiales federales y
metropolitanas de todo el distrito de
columbia en las calles el centro de
washington permanece intensamente
tranquilo
aquí en el distrito las cosas parecen
calmarse la situación es incierta pero
al mismo tiempo tenemos mucha confianza
en nuestra capacidad para responder a
cualquier cosa y responder en insein
estado en varias misiones antes nada
como esto en sí respondía disturbios en
el pasado en baltimore pero nunca vi
nada a la escala de esto o al menos en
cantidad de tropas que se han movilizado
en la capital de la nación no nunca
imaginé esto ampliamente criticada por
su manejo del asalto del 6 de enero la
policía del capitolio de estados unidos
ahora está armada y en alerta máxima una
muestra de la aplicación de la ley que
ha tranquilizado a muchos residentes de
washington gracias a todos dios los
bendiga incluso el servicio secreto
generalmente encargado de proteger al
presidente de eeuu y a otros altos
funcionarios está disponible para ayudar
a proteger el área pero es muy triste
deberían haber estado más preparados y
en alerta la semana pasada esto es un
gran misterio
y perturbador así que tengo sentimientos
encontrados la última vez que vi
soldados aquí fue en el 11 de septiembre
cuando estábamos bajo ataque extranjero
ahora hay más soldados aquí que en
afganistán y es porque un grupo de
estadounidenses nos ha atacado
el despliegue actual es mayor que el de
afganistán siria e irak juntos una señal
de que las autoridades se están tomando
muy en serio la amenaza de un nuevo
ataque interno